what's goody hopper at the verse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros i am your
host comedian joel byers and our mission
here is to cultivate the next generation
of great comics by interviewing today's
great comics and our guest today
is the first comic i saw live
and i was like oh there's levels to this
comedy thing
every time i've seen him it's been an
absolute murder on stage and it's you
know he's been in the game over 30 years
but it did start you know back when he
was a rapper and beatboxer as a fat free
i believe and uh he's since been rising
the ranks doing shows at chinese family
reunions and now arenas around the world
and fresh off his first grammy
nomination
welcome to the hot breath verse the one
and only lavelle crawford my friend
welcome thank you man thank you very
much and i'm glad i got to look to my
inbox and seeing that you guys sent me a
message we out here i just you know i
started doing that the last couple of
years man i just really wouldn't even go
in there and look yeah
have messages and ask me to do some cool
stuff but it'd be like seven months
later oh my god i can't believe i missed
that
that's what people will ask me like how
do i get so many like dope people on the
show and i was like well you know
ask yeah maybe if you ask yeah
you know closed mouth don't get fed
that's what i heard yeah and now we've
interviewed over 400 comics on here so
it's fantastic it's been building and
building and what what i loved about
researching your career is that actually
we share the similarity that i saw
sinbad
and was like yo i want to do that now it
was afros and bell bottoms i think you
saw him live while you were in college
yeah yeah he was a young he was he he
had just fresh off of uh the kaiser show
his first debut on the cops show right
before he became a teacher on different
worlds before they even did the spin-off
so yeah yeah he was both young i mean he
was way older than me he was older
little older than me so he was a young
dude just looking for it what was what
was it about him that
was like made you want to be like all
right i want to do comedy instead of
beatboxing well
well well first of all i took third in
the talent show with that beatbox where
i rapped and that deep beatbox and
everybody else that was in the group
got stage fright
and and i knew that i had something
because i was fearless on the stage for
some reason i'd like to be up there
and i you know but when i met him and i
watched him you know the thing is it's
like
you you see a lot of
you know that just you know ethnic in
your master background black man your
white man you like your young white
comic and you watch your own peers you
know white guys that you know but you
saw sinbad yeah but see i when i was
in college i didn't see any black
comments i think i think the only time i
thought richard pryor
and
i think richard brady murphy's the only
ones that allowed black to do comedy
at that time you know what i'm saying
then i knew bill cosby but then after i
started researching he started looking
around i was like man it was being
comedian black immediately but you know
before you know
we had the cable
booming for cape of comedy came up we
didn't know that i didn't know learned
about because but i seen a lot of you
know like comedians mainstream comedians
come to our college and they were funny
you know but i just didn't know how i
never talked to those guys but when
sinbad came
he just really put a fire in me and he
was he was so honest he was so nice and
and he talked about his first time he
had a big gig he was up for earth
winning fire and uh you know how earth
went to fire they legendary you know
come on i mean
and they they was like in kansas city
and they was yelling out you know they
getting high it's like you know about 5
000 people there oh y'all ready for
earth wind and fire and god earth y'all
really cry oh you know i mean they
launching
and they said buttfur
yeah they put that butt first on pull us
back and he had to come up there and try
to follow that but first and they were
booing it oh they were going crazy he
said for some reason he just he knew
that was a
was a green light for him to win him
over and once he
he got him he got him because you know
they were just you know how people just
read it but p everyone loves to laugh i
mean if you're gonna be funny just be
funny you can't let them beat you
so
and then and he said once i seen that i
knew that i could do this and like i
watch him he has great crowd control
he has and and sinbad is a funny thing
about him he always strives to be a
clean comic right and but offstage he
cuts like a sailor yeah yeah he's so
funny it's so funny because i know him
personally so it's just like man i like
new people with that crap on himself did
they they didn't know that you knew how
you talk on stage right because like
when the bill cosby didn't come up
because he was a real supporter of bill
cosby he was just because
and he was going off and you know i was
like all right man you know we know man
and
we just go pray for him let it let it be
so but you know he was always a good
dude and it was an honor for me to
to do to do the uh
the celebrity uh
benefit for us you know have the stroke
man because you know i was like that's
it bad man dude i don't care what they
call about kings of comedy and stuff i
mean saying bad it's solidified oh yeah
you understand oh dude hundreds of
things to do to do
and sinbad's life his his comedy life
almost is almost it's almost like we're
on the same track but i ain't had a
sitcom he hadn't had a couple of sitcoms
he didn't people don't even understand
sinbad been hitting it for a long time
but he always keep going mm-hmm
and that's one thing i respect about him
that's what i was like i was talking we
were actually going back and forth
before he had the stroke about doing the
show and we were just getting scheduling
down and then he had a stroke and they
like disappeared and i was just like oh
man i hope he's all right because
for me he's he's on my mount rushmore
like
he's who i saw and then he's one of
those people that just has fun on stage
and you have fun on stage you know oh
yeah it's a
i i can't take myself serious i can't
take myself for granted but i can't take
myself here because you got to think
about this if we take the layers off of
comedy let's just say take the skin off
of a chicken and get to the meat take
the meat off of the chicken and get to
the bone it's just a bone this was a
real creature that we freaking eaten and
this would have life he had thoughts he
would have fears
and but it was just something it was a
chicken but we already paid ten dollars
for a whole bucket of it and we don't
even realize what it went through to be
there but
with this comedy if you take the layers
off of chapel layers off of chris wright
lads i'm kevin hart lays off a sandbag
and be honest with yourself
we are all
freaking
making a living
telling jokes
things that are funny to us and getting
paid for it
yes the public speaking part does take a
little bit of
but do we get blessed people packing in
to see me and i'm sitting up here
thinking i'm this
dom like
where is comedian
i can't i can't i can't even get one
side on the rubik's cube but you know
you know i've ever thinking i'm so
special you know but i mean but you know
i do have a skill that some people can't
grasp and that's the beautiful thing
about it but it's how i explored it and
and making people trust me
that's the whole
whole i think the whole talent the
professional part getting people to
trust that they know when they come to
see you
you they know they're gonna come out of
this mug laughing they butt off how do
you how do you uh build that trust
go up and be funny just murder any and
it's not even murder the crowd it's just
like man get out there and not not you
have confidence in what you're talking
about and you know and and not
understand it like you know you oh you
have sex you see
when i
started i had sex that i would go up and
i talked about and i you know because i
usually you know i lost a few pounds i'm
a little slimmer than i was and before
and i used to do the fat jokes and
people say yeah you know we know you
bring it back down
if you lose weight what you gonna do and
i said well
i think i'm gonna be funny as hell
because my whole thing is you don't
understand i'm a tactician a tactician i
i understand that in the art of war you
have to find a way in the door and see
and the thing about me is you had to
come in showing
that you're humble or weak and then you
are strong and but the thing about me
i come in and talk about the elephant in
the room first i'm gonna look that's
little kid
look at that lady got a booger in her
nose yeah that kid brings it up so it
can get out of the way so when i used to
talk about my weight i get that out of
the way and you know how comfortable
people become when you joke about
yourself because you don't understand
it may be 3 400 people in there and i
guarantee
all of them have insecurities i don't
care if the prettiest woman or the most
good looking guy the most in shape guy
most of the time and
they are going through something and if
you joke about yourself they don't that
takes the power from them and it also
it also gives them empowers them because
they're like man you know hey man i mean
like it's simple it's easy i mean i joke
about myself it's cool see and once you
become that person see that's what
they're really the world is trying to do
is take that away from people from not
joking about anything you're like oh
you're making a joke about my sexuality
no i'm not i'm making a joke about it
because you're a person and we're
supposed to joke about everything going
on quirky guys quirky things we it's
just funny so you can make if you make
people laugh about it they won't judge
you no more if you you comfortable in
your skin you in nobody really says
anything but you want to bully somebody
into not you know 79 i heard
now you can't call people fat anymore
and i'm like man i wish i'd stay stay
bigger i would have never had weight
loss surgery if i knew it was illegal
for you to put me down you know because
i mean i heard it all my life you know
but i mean but my understanding is
that's a cop-out because it don't make
you better when you start getting
accepted it don't make you better even
if you somebody make a joke about your
sexuality i'm going to be praying for my
sexuality because it's what i want to do
if i'm a prayer for the way i look i
look this way i'm cool with the way i
look i may joke about it but i i mean
i'm walking around i'm the real crowd
with people breaking they need to come
and take pictures with me and be
around me so i don't have to in depth
before and that's how i thought before i
became this lavelle crawford you know
what i'm saying yeah and i said when i
got on stage i would joke about it and
you know i mean
and then of course you have those people
that want to call you you got some
chicken i'll feed you you know you got
those goofy people but my son said
something to me just the other day that
was powerful with your fans you suffer
fools also you have to understand that
some people
are not going to be civilized they're
going to come at you weird and you have
to just know how to navigate around them
without even getting them because see
they love you but they thinking like oh
he said that and sometimes when you hear
it again you know because i heard and i
and i do this i talk about all of this
because
i i see a lot of women comedians you
know how you know from amy schumer to uh
comedians that i know back in the day
that would get on stage and be real
raunchy
sheryl underwood all of them but when a
man would come up to him after the show
say hey what's going on
i ain't like yeah and get an attitude
but the thing is you don't have to do
nothing with this guy but you can scare
him
which is oh man what you got pull it out
i mean you know you got to stay in your
character because that's who you are now
somebody said you got some chicken i
said i'm already ate man i don't like
that kind of chicken you don't have to
come better than a little bitty wing
minute i'll kill that in a couple of
seconds you know just something and just
walk away because see you're gonna have
you got to understand you got to stay
stay stronger in your truth once you
stay strong in your tooth because when i
used to do the factory i do the fat
jokes about how people were reacting to
me
and how they acted to me and how you
know how i had to come at it like my
baby stared had fat people the whole
nine yards yeah yeah kid looking at you
the whole time like he's some kind of uh
something from a jurassic park coming in
that's going to eat him then a parent
picking them up like you like you that
ate a kid before and i used to do things
like that but it's funny because it
takes away that that that that armor and
then what i watch on other fact
comedians are larger comedians that
that's that's up and coming i see that
they're following the same rhythm like
ronnie jordan he ducks about his way
yeah he's killed i mean i mean ronnie
jordan's like yo he's one of my one of
my students he watched me so many times
you know and i mean
i mean we talked all the time he said i
was one of his heroes and because i was
i stayed in my truth
and see it and and that's the real thing
about it but then
i was on the radio interview recently
man i got a lot of honesty this weekend
this young lady told me she said you
don't understand man you you you're the
only comedian i know
that reinvents itself all the time
and i didn't even know that i was doing
they said from you know you've gone on
breaking bad you're going you've been on
tyler perry move but then you get on
breaking bad you didn't last confident
standing but you also didn't death jam
you you're the dog's weight and you you
know and talking about that but i said
but that i said well i think and this is
something a comedian should understand
when you doing your thing
your comedy is just like
your dream and it's your dream and what
i say man about that if you ever watch
like freddy krueger right freddy krueger
will come in your dream and he'll tell
you he'll take your dream turn it
against you and wind up killing your
dream because he freaks you out excuse
you so much because it's a nightmare but
you see that always the answer to that
all the time was the person who was in
the dream who controlled his nightmare
became the nightmare or became this is
my dream so you just you control the
narrative it's your dream you in my
dreams so you know freddie you ain't
gonna do that in my dream [ __ ] your ass
now and and once you understand that
this you're writing your story
this is your story so you get on stage
you talk about what the hell you want to
talk about you be who you are
you you don't let people dig you you're
not there
to
make friends you're there to be a
comedian because a greatest comedian has
never had people
and he please he went into people
pleasing business that's impossible oh i
mean chappelle just got jumped on stage
like a few days ago well and then and
but that that that i can't really even
wait it up because what i heard was this
guy was a rapper he was a clown chaser
oh okay you know what i found out he was
he was he was a rapper and he was trying
to get some clout and you know i thought
that he'd get up on because he he said
he got a rap song where he talked about
he's called chappelle and the whole
thing's crazy man wow you don't even
understand it was just the opportunity
but it's just the thing
but yeah he did jump on stage and it was
weird and then and people are thinking
because he was talking about the
transgender i said no
do you think more people are going to
start doing that though
i mean they've been doing things like
like jumping i mean i mean right here
right here gary owens had a guy and it
wasn't a black guy it was a yeah it was
a it was a good old boy got up on stage
at him and they had security he had to
grab him down remember that yeah i do so
he said we forget we always forget we
got to think about man you if you watch
uh
they had the uh
the the what is it uh the comedy story
they reunion they were talking about the
comic store and they talked about the
good the bad and the ugly of comedy and
they saw this one guy who played the
guitar and the guy said and this guy was
you know you suck you know come up early
say that you know he said you suck he
said hey man you better stay away from
this stage or you're gonna get it he
said what you gonna do and he came up
there and the guy broke the good talk
with his head and the crowd kind of got
mad at him for breaking his guitar and
said hey he came at me you know but they
they show some guy
he was doing a regular comedy night and
some guy and he kept on making fun of
this guy but see the thing about we got
to understand it's two sides to every
story and it's two sides to everything
dave's thing that was weird that was
some club chasing
but comedians
got to understand
we all get caught in caught in this
this tornado of machismo especially men
we we we don't know how to pull our ego
down and understand man this guy's
vulnerable if he's getting this mad
let's relinquish it because you got 300
people in here that didn't want you to
get in a fight with him why don't you
let security get him out or all right
man i gotta love you dog let's not even
go there you know you got to find a way
to take it take it out take the power
away from the devil or whoever and and
pull back because he you keep going at
somebody and going at somebody
basically now you're punching him and he
can't swing back so what he's going to
do he going to attack you he going to
try to come on stage you don't want that
because they'll take you out of your
element because you can't recover even
though dave recovered it wasn't he still
didn't recover because they was over
there beating the [ __ ] out of a guy
while everybody was on stage and they
were shook i don't give a [ __ ] nobody
say i know me as a comedian i i i know
martial arts i know a lot of things i
can do but i don't want to get in a
position where i have to hurt somebody
and i'm a comedian that ain't my job to
be beating the [ __ ] out of nobody yeah i
mean only mike tyson didn't even want to
beat the [ __ ] out of that guy on the
plane you understand they [ __ ] with mike
tyson people who got a problem where
they you know they caught they try to
get you know you got to understand and
mike was being peaceful and i mean
you poke the bear brother and i mean you
better thank god he didn't get you brain
damage because i mean he could have
really hurt that guy
but the shameful thing is why did he
have to because he was minding his
business mike get
i've been around mike tyson i mean he
when he he's sober he chill he ain't
even he really kind of scared of a
person like me because he know i got
words
and you know and i ain't no little dude
but i ain't gonna fight the [ __ ]
he's gonna beat my ass i ain't trying to
do that i ain't trying to go to hobby
even if i get a little kid i'm gonna
look stupid yeah i'll post them though
yeah but yeah you go they said you ain't
gonna have your kidneys mm-hmm
you pissed all of yourself all right
we're we've approached our 20. oh okay
um um so i i won't hold you up um we got
time we got a little time yeah
i got two i got too many i got two more
comedians before my name
i just wanted to be uh respectful of
your time
you're you're lavelle crawford i'll let
you know if we have to wrap it up with
that we good right now i appreciate that
yeah that's that's respect because
you're you're a comedian man like
i saw you
at the uptown not the original but i saw
you at the uptown that was next to the
strip club okay that was the first time
i saw you and i was just like
yo like because what you're you're like
yeah we're comedians we're funny but
like
the
it's like i don't think i'd seen it
again until earthquakes new special
like that's probably the next time i've
seen someone just kill that heart and as
a comedian
like i came up in the hood rooms here in
atlanta like i'm white boy joel i'm
white boy joe i'm the plug on white
people around here
so like i'm used to like
in like white rooms it's more about like
how cool are you and who do you know but
like in urban rooms it's like if you're
funny you you get on stage you know so
i'm just used to seeing like killing and
then to see you kill that heart i was
like
how like did you
when did you because you've been doing
over 30 years what was the point where
you're like oh i'm really like i'm like
really like firing on all cylinders now
where it's just like a laughs the entire
show
i
work work at it worth it reps
it's like muscle memory i think you know
once you start you're doing a uh
once you start doing it
you can feel
the energy and then you know how to
switch gears like i was on stage the
first show i was just i was just you
know playing talking about things i
wanted to talk about and
if i got laughers
it's all you know i i i'm a fisherman
like
people always wonder how pro bass
fishermen they catch all these fish
they don't ever catch every fish and
then when they catching every fish they
catching all the fish that bite but you
got about
two two three thousand of the fish that
ain't [ __ ] with that fake lure they
ain't [ __ ] with nothing you got they
know not to do it you got the smart ones
and the donuts you're catching the
dumbells and but i don't call my lava
dumbers i call them people that came out
to enjoy themselves but those people are
the triggers to make everybody else
laugh and then once you get them
laughing you can you can go anyway up
there and say so when i'm up there and
i'm doing it i say oh man i and my brain
i'm just directing how i want to punch
them and i said oh i'm gonna hit him
with this and i oh i'm just doing this
why not talk about that you know i mean
and i in my brain is going i'm i am on
uh eight cell of the v i'm on a
cleveland football i know i want to
cleveland for a girl i know my brain
[Music]
and i mean but somebody else be like man
i should have did this but sometimes you
have those moments where you feel it
when you feel that moment where
everything is clicking and clicking and
clicking that's how you practice your
your comedy to always find the clicks
and you can find once you get in there
because i mean when i first
i when i got a comment view when i was
doing a comic video they gave you four
five to five to seven minutes so you had
to come with it and i was always i had
jokes with punch punch five five or five
and i always would do it like that and
sometimes you want to give them the ride
and i think when they come to a big show
you want to give them the roller coaster
ride you want to have that right
maybe they didn't even know they've been
out there only about three minutes they
didn't almost lost their life 17 times
and then they go
like oh my god and that's exactly what
you want to give them if you could give
them that
it's a great reward like i only did 52
videos that first show you i i sometimes
you know stayed all day and night man
cuz i could talk but i said no man i'm
getting i'm getting grown man i don't
want to do that all the time yeah i
wanna break my break my back trying to
be over funny because i know i got you
they already know i'm funny they already
they come because of all the [ __ ] i have
done
so when i come in and then they get to
laugh with me and i'm doing more [ __ ] in
front of them it's just another level oh
my god you know you know i'm up here now
so i can do anything i want
and and really like every set i've seen
you do is like different so like i mean
you're extremely prolific like are you
writing on stage or do you do like pen
to paper like what or how has it evolved
over the years from where i started i'm
writing all day
and i don't pen and paper but i'm
writing all day if i watch the news i
listen to people talk people tell me
things i'm always figuring it out and
thinking about it funny
and i think i'm always right
just thinking about man we'll talk about
that and i might just get up on stage
and talk i talk about me and my wife had
an argument today and i talked about it
because i you know sometimes it's my
best therapy getting on stage and just
letting it out of me you know i mean the
waiting room i'm talking about the
eyelashes
and then she got to my eyelashes and i
didn't want to say it to her and hurt
her feelings what she would do right but
i talked about it on stage
[Laughter]
even though i joked about it i didn't
say no more to her about it so i got on
stage and i didn't pick her out you know
questions
you know and i realized you don't have
to make fun of somebody sometimes
sometimes i do
mess with people because how the energy
is and i mess with them but it don't be
it'd be so funny that they had to break
down and laugh because they can't they
can't sit there because it's not that
i'm putting them down and i call them
the [ __ ] or punk [ __ ] i'm not
i'm not giving them
i'm not making them feel bad but i'm
joking about them i got one last time i
was here i think this guy was out there
i said he he didn't this guy's a
mathematician he didn't even care about
the show he's up there doing the
equation at the table on the bill how
much how much the excise tax if you take
nine into two the square root of five
and i was on the side see you're not
listening and i went into this whole
thing of how he would he was giving me
the book the the stink guy but he
started breaking he started breaking
good
he had to laugh because you know i mean
everybody around him was on the floor
you know and sometimes but i wouldn't
but he couldn't get mad because i was
saying you were smart
i'm not i'm not putting you down that's
the thing about with the chris rock
thing
he caught a g.i jean that was a hot ass
movie back in the 80s or 90s
and and of course taylor picker would
take that role she would take their role
immediately they gave her gi jam too and
the thing about it is
i just you know i but i see people see
when it comes back in people's face well
you think people are going to start
doing that my whole thing is they've
been yeah you know
steve brown
yeah but see and then i love steve but
we gotta keep it real they steve steve
said he seemed to do slap his slap his
wife and his mama
why are you talking to him
that dude doing that crap
hey security
let's get him out of here he needs some
rest and if he ain't gonna go i'm gonna
walk on stage let that brother cool down
because i'm not gonna that right there
is like
a tiger's loose but i'm gonna go get out
of here tiger no you don't do that i
don't care if i can't fight i'm not
gonna see he said he got an arm cut and
all that stuff and he said he'd been
true he's been traumatized by but i said
he was you
he wasn't your job
to keep on talking to this dude and you
yeah you said people had your back and i
and i understand steve and like i said
that machismo get in there and you think
you can handle it and he did he he had
boxing skills and all that but my whole
energy was dude
when they like that
let them go
let them let them leave
it's better that you do that than then
sit up there
and get yourself in something stupid
because basically that what i have saw
he crazy
everybody at the table crazy with him
you understand you don't know who else
crazy and they ain't they ain't out out
loud crazy they gonna come up there with
him
and whip your ass or whatever they gonna
do you know i'm saying he with some
people so it's like
don't
push yourself in there i mean i i just
seen some i think who is that
who is that comedian what's it
shoot i remember mike yes well go say
you ain't laughing at me he'd be in five
minutes and walk off stage back in his
early days like man yeah he laughing at
me i'm here going home as i brought him
down and everything yeah i've been
knowing these guys a long time sounds
like you at broner's brothers oh yeah 2
a.m
then you dip early on that one no
actually i did
i finished my act oh i thought you left
your set early because you're like
she told you to be clean and then you're
like effort yeah well yeah oh my god
that was that was uh
that was i didn't leave though honestly
i did i went up doing 25 30 minutes oh
okay i stayed up there but everybody
else was leaving
you know so i was like what did i do
i mean you know i thought
it was seemed like a great crowd right
man that went up they all these guys
went up and they were doing blue
i mean pat brown funny female comedian
she she she she had brought me up damon
williams damon williams who went up he
killed what he was doing he was doing
dirty jokes but she going you be clean
and i was like
pat said this no no
yeah yeah
who i won't have to ever worry about she
would love to have me do our show now
but yesterday's price is not today's
price
price is that today's price sweetheart
thank you sweetie you have a nice day
okay
but
she
came to me and said that so i'm doing
clean and i had no problem with that i
do church
but my whole energy was it was like man
they do dirty i'll come and do clean
it's not gonna blend because but i
thought that when i wasn't doing dirty
the crowd was like oh he cleaned i gotta
go but but that's where i met my wife
lovely design i met my wife there at the
valley that that was during valentine's
day weekend wow and uh
and i
and i got mad i was just like done
i was just like man i was hurt man
because i said it was a big show they
bragged on how big it is and i'm just
thinking to myself man
what what did i do man people just
walking out on me you know i said they
didn't like me but when i walked in the
back
that's when damon williams came and got
me say hey lavell it's about two three
hundred people out here
on pictures
so i'm like i know everybody was gone
but it wasn't that they was walking out
they said the buses was leaving my wife
that's the wife that i met my woman my
my wife now she was she was there she
was one of the women taking a picture
with me and i called the blue jeans man
it was like kind of a chance meeting
because she had whispered where are you
staying at and i wouldn't tell her
exactly where i was standing i told her
the whole time but i ain't telling her
what room but she caught fake like she
was my wife and was able to leave a
message on my bro so that's how ironic
talk about speaking some of the
existence yeah it might be the pivotal
interview to turn it over
let's go you know so so when she said
that
when i called her back and we talked we
talked for hours and and lo and behold
he had some moments in himself but it
was it was meant to be
and we've been married ever since going
on 15 years but she the one said no they
was leaving because the buses was
leaving
and they had to get on this baby you
know some of them weren't staying
downtown they were staying out and the
crazy thing about it my hotel was just
we had went me and tony roberts and
damian williams had walked
from my hotel in the days at the uh
holiday inn at the time over to the days
ends when he had a diner downstairs to
eat he had a denny's down there i think
you feel that it had a denny down there
we went down there to eat me and him and
i guess they had met some females so and
i'm just sitting there man i just i
wanted something to eat she was in that
hotel but strange enough we never we
never saw each other that night but the
next the next day we talked on the phone
taught on the phone and then we wind up
everything started meshing together it
was interesting you know i honestly i i
knew a girl down there but she didn't
show up and
so i i was mad about that
i didn't know her at the time so but if
we wind up i guess there was a reason
why she didn't show up because i was
meeting the one for me
so
that's beautiful yeah that's beautiful
yeah it's so funny how comedy does that
too like comedy like breaks you down
just to like build you up it's like
like if something bad happens you you're
like i kind of look at like the lower
the lows the higher the highs if like if
something if uh her heroic bomb happens
like oh something good's on the other
side of this yeah you you you that's how
you should speak even if you if if you
don't happen right away it's just like
last comment standing man it was like i
just i thought it was in the bag but i
knew it wasn't in the bag when we went
to the rehearsal because
they they were
this guy one of the extras that heard
the producer saying
you know yeah we we make a joke about
level cause they they were gonna carry
john reef in on on this big old like
royalty uh platform with the band
playing on the side and they're gonna
have just regular people walk down with
me and i had to walk down
you know and i was just like why are
they doing that what kind of crap is
this and so they knew who they was gonna
pick as the winner and i told and i went
to the blues i said well you know what i
won't be here tonight i told him i said
i'm not coming you already know who the
[ __ ] y'all wanna win i said i'm not
going to embarrass me in my family we'll
go have dinner and [ __ ] this
and they and they they pulled me to the
side said lavell i don't know what
you're talking about i don't know what
you heard i said i heard it from the
horse's mouth yeah i i know you didn't
pick me as a [ __ ] winner it's okay i
said i made i helped you i'm sure you
helped me and i appreciate it i'm out
and i was leaving they went and they
chased me down and they threw the
contract in my face i said don't give a
[ __ ] about no contract i don't need that
[ __ ]
i ain't never been that person you can't
scare me with that
and they were like well please please
come tonight please come tonight and and
and they called me and they got a car
service to come and give me the whole
night make sure i showed up
they got me a suit
because i have a suit they may got me
bought me a suit
and uh when we went up of course
i didn't win
and i sit up there and look down my
brother he in the room he had tears
running out he was [ __ ] big ass baby
crying my sister crying i'm i'm [ __ ]
mad as [ __ ] but
and then i come i'm in my dressing room
just sit down and they said hey we're
gonna need that suit back no
true story
should we bring st louis out on
oh my god even man
but you know and i thought to myself i
was angry that i didn't win right but
the funny thing was
right after that i had to go to the
[ __ ] comedy works in denver
i walk in there some it's and it's sold
out
all weekend
ouch
everywhere i went
sold out
then i was saying oh
i won
yup i won then
i was hitting it like that so hard and
everything
i was
in canada i get a call i was supposed to
be on that movie come back with uh with
uh
ice cube if you ever remember that movie
come back he had a
young lady uh what's her name akilah and
to be uh
what's her name
ki
kia kiki palmer
was in it uh i was supposed to be in
that
but they had already booked me for it
but the
limp biscuit [ __ ] who directed it
some [ __ ] got mad i ain't know that guy
how the [ __ ] you're gonna put him in his
movie without my permission he was the
director so he kicked me off the movie
because i was like wow i'm getting a
movie off of this so i had i was in the
mix but it was okay because after that i
got another movie with uh
uh
christian stewart and jesse eisenberg
that were american ultra and you know
everything started opening man i mean
then breaking bad heartbreaking bad
comes i know all these things from last
comment standard and i said so when you
say
you bomb real big you know some good
coming from it i ain't bombed but i lost
and i just thought oh my god i could
have used that money i wish i could have
got that
i think and everything i thought why god
you didn't let me win and what i got to
keep going through this you know white
devil won
it anything like i did
you know the thing about john
john was fighting demons but john was a
sweetheart man you know i have
he couldn't ever ever do a nicer dude at
least he's funny at least he's like not
funny and still one and like yeah but
like he at least
was funny and he's likeable yeah and he
was a sweet guy he was going through
some commercial series he married this
lady and she was just not the one and he
was drinking his [ __ ] ass down under
the [ __ ] bed i don't know why he was
drinking so [ __ ] much
and then he had to follow me
and i and you know that white black
crowd whatever
it don't matter i'm level you know so it
was ugly dude yeah yeah i'm
dude and seeing it again tonight i'm
like
i'm like just watching it just like
hearing the laughter and like i'll keep
track two of like i'll um i'll like keep
a timer as well and like next time i
look down it's 20 minutes and i was like
the laughter is like every laugh is a
house laugh there's no like little
pitter patter every single thing hits so
it's like
i'm 12 years in and i i it's a lifelong
journey like i feel good where i'm at in
terms of just like i'm not you know
doing open mics bombing you know at 1am
in front of bartenders but yeah it's how
i don't know 12 years in part of me i
have to like fight that urge to be like
where's mine you can't you can't count
the years yeah why are you counting the
years what's your expectations what was
your expectation in 12 years
i don't even think i just want to be
full-time which i am i guess i just
wanted to make comedy my job and it is
and the thing about and the thing about
that if you
you got a podcast for any [ __ ] guest
you you're fine in your rhythm 12 10
years in you it's really getting your
feet back because the first five six man
your ass [ __ ] just i don't know what
i'm talking about
uh
you'll know when
let's say
20 years from now i talked to you again
and i i might even see you on stage and
you have to
cruising
just cruising the stage
like you watch me how i cruise the stage
because once you get past
all the expectations
that's what you do when you because what
you do is
like i always give analogy because that
because i can't explain i can say it in
words but i think you you have why
dragon ball z yeah yeah okay you know
how
goku went from
goku and he had the tail and the monkey
power then he went into super saiyan i
think it was super saiyan super saiyan
then super saiyan two and three and he
went all the way up to super super
saiyan god and blah blah blah he went
all the way up there but then he went to
pass super grand he went to ultimate
instinct but when he turned in the
ultimate instinct this whole shell broke
off of him and he was just goku
[Music]
you understand he was just goku but he
was so powerful
he was he had no colors he had [ __ ] he
he had a little glow but he was cool
that
is where you go when you come back to
just being you
when you give back to just being you
you're unstoppable because you're
self-actualized you understand that
nobody can [ __ ] with me
you just let go of expectations is that
what you say yeah expectations yeah you
know you know you should never you're
always going to get up and do well on
stage but you shouldn't get out there
like we're in about 10 years where i'm
at yeah i mean you're doing what you
love man yeah that's true i mean man
dude if
my brother he made it into the nfl
he could always talk about that
even he was with michael vick he [ __ ]
got drafted this [ __ ] little [ __ ]
stupid kid that i used to beat up and
torture all the time
he [ __ ] made it he said he was gonna
play in the pros and he made it all the
way to the nfl i mean he got cut but
[ __ ] he made it yeah you understand what
i'm saying dude and if you'd have got to
play how many years do you play
you know because that was your pinnacle
so you understand when you put yourself
in a plateau where you start let's say
you start working nationally in 10 years
now what's your experience i need movies
i need to come i need this i need
grammys i need you know it's a great
white voice
it's like a little bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's all i'm doing i'm
not even white or black i'm just like
whining about what yeah what why you
know cause you could see after a while
man like where i'm at i just want to
i've been blessed to make a
a lot of money
and my will
you know it's a blessing to be there
and make this money but it's a also a
courage that i haven't
finally i've got property i bought a
house um you know
i bought my wife franchise we finally
got that going we we i want to take the
money that god blessed me with to i get
i don't have to work break my back to do
it to leave something uh uh some kind of
inheritance as hell because i could get
like deja pal of course i should be and
i should have a lot of [ __ ] with if i
got deja pal money but right now i've
got level money and i could make a lot
of a lot of doors because i used to i
knew a comic he's a preacher down here
now
very good dude
and uh
you know
[ __ ] listening his name now
because i'm because because i'm i'm
grown and i brought his name up i'm
sitting there rodney the rodney and his
name is rodney and uh ronnie but
i think it was the last name before i
get he still does comedy or he doesn't
know he's a preacher
i don't think i don't think he's going
to comedy no more but but rodney told me
he was a touring comic okay
rodney bought four houses
rodney had neces he used his money that
he got and he invested but he was a
military guy he got out of the military
he got married he got divorced and he
went to a uh
different steps in his life to be where
he is and it's incredible
that he he had told me you just got to
invest your money hold it you take the
moneys that you get and man i i was a
promoter i made money then there i mean
i had i've i already show you what kind
of money i got
i gotta pay these [ __ ] back and
and i mean
about it i wish i had some of that money
but the thing about squandering your
squandering your squandering squandering
your money because i ain't have nobody
to show me how to do i had an uncle to
tell me that's what you should do but he
didn't show me because i'm not i'm not a
dumb person but i i need someone to
guide me is that the uncle that was a
clown
do you have an uncle it's a clown
in my research i had that that you have
an uncle that was a clown maybe you were
clowning on your uncle
maybe you're like he's a clown like he's
not really like yeah he ain't like that
like that he clowned dang i tried to do
a deep cut on that one i try to i tried
to go deep on these interviews i tried
to pull i tried to pull down a spade
right there you got something today
i don't know
right that'd be it yeah he probably i
got some ate some clowns that act silly
he used to be a funny [ __ ] man
yeah i mean he keeps the statements on
his mind he did he had a lot of fun and
[ __ ] happened to him
he's always been a funny dude you know
but you're talking about all this money
though but you know i'll go headline up
in maryland for you know 200 bucks
so like that that's where i'm at right
now dude i've been i've been there of
course then i've gone and done like
other gigs for five grand
my way through canada came back with 175
dollars i did saskatchewan wine i've
done i was in bemidji minnesota i've
done all these places and i came back
175 dollars
wow
hey
if gas was cheap thank god that was
cheap but i didn't make no money i've
done
i've done a lot of things for [ __ ]
free yeah
i remember the first gig i got for 250
freaking dollars and my head gasket blew
off blew up on my car and i had to use a
whole 250 give him a coffee
i did that with my alternator before
yeah yeah yeah
i mean but 200
yeah it's the you know when i i didn't
even know how to get paid at comedy at
one time
but i loved doing it because i was
getting i get free snacks for [ __ ]
drinks i had a good time getting on
stage and i you know meeting people
it was it was that was the moments you
know that i that i had missed
you know what i'm saying now
everybody get it it's like i didn't get
to a point where i i'm flying but
everybody that i used to be
on the ground with
they i still love them but they don't
talk to me the same we don't get to
blend no more because they think they
can't act around me you know what i mean
yeah yeah and that's a that's a like
when i got this grammy nomination nobody
really freaking knew
nobody knew and i and i mean they they
talked about it right on
nbc
tv it was right out there lavell
crawford everybody know my freaking name
and i mean none of my friends
that i thought was my friend i still
they my friends and i'll hold them
accountable i mean because jealousy is a
horrible monster you know
it's a painful monster that that some
people can't get out of and they won't
say they're jealous but why you ain't
coming because i called like earthquake
special
he called me and i told a man fantastic
special but but it ain't no big deal it
was a 30-minute special earthquake the
headliner he my specialist was all my
best for the hour yeah i only got one
30-minute one that was on the on premium
bullying
all my spencer was and then the bet one
all my [ __ ] is ours
and i did the same thing and now yeah
that's true so my thing is earthquake
earthquake i mean he'd been that funny
for a long time what he was doing it
wasn't amazing to me because people oh
he killed i'm like
i knew earthquake way back in the
freaking day earthquake was [ __ ]
slotted he was stronger back then he is
now
wow and now he's corporate
what he's corporate now yeah i mean he
got radio shows since you know when you
start getting that kind of [ __ ] yeah
it's a different you're not the same not
as raw anymore not the animal he was joe
that i'm seeing his i can't stop talking
about his special like
rodney perry called me because he was
like i believe you sold more earthquake
specials than anyone like because i just
keep talking about everyone i see i
asked them about it like have you every
comic i'm like have you seen the
earthquake special you gotta see it like
it's just what's the only reason you say
that
because
when i
i'm not [ __ ] on this special it was
great i didn't even see it but i saw
i've worked with him all year i know
yeah yeah so
but the thing about it is
my my special kind of brother get in
love
probably was the last
days of pills
you could give daisy pals his because
that's where everybody always talk about
it it's it's indoctrinated in our mind
but if we was all on the same playing
field and my special kind of brother get
some love everybody and i ain't saying
this trying to help your ego i'm special
the hottest [ __ ] they had on that
[ __ ] for a
long time
my [ __ ] i became famous off that special
when they put it on there it wasn't a
netflix special but when they put my
special on there that [ __ ] blew up like
powder cage but see i should have been
one of the people they were sought after
but then they got chris tucker which his
special was cool they put they got kevin
hart kevin hardy ain't really pulled
nothing since let me explain because he
became corporate dave chappelle still
funny but despair is cocky funny where
he can sit on stage and talk when he was
on killing me softly when he was looking
at and he was he was still gritty
you got to understand when you start
making that kind of money and you saw
people start keep on boosting your
[ __ ] ego like you said i'm great i
know how to do these these jokes i i can
do turn anything into yeah you only can
do that because everybody
there to adore you
let's say you fall off you try to come
back like five heartbeat eddie kane jr
and you come back and try to get on
stage and try to pull that off
it ain't the same thing you know
understanding yeah yeah yeah yeah i hear
you and we'll we'll definitely uh we do
a live stream every tuesday where we
break down comedy specials we'll
definitely we'll definitely do yours
just for the uh yeah so we left it's not
it's not a it's not none of the things i
say to let me do that disclaimer because
people got soft skin now earthquake
special was incredible and i'm proud of
them
dave's repair i never met him but it'll
be an honor now i hope he's a fan of
mine as well as me of his
but
it's just like i'm gonna tell you i'm
gonna give you a prime example can't
wait
can't we got nine [ __ ] better
his first eight
was
outstanding you understand cause cat go
hard
and the thing about it was kevin cap was
very distinguished but cad was never
corporate corporate he never got in they
never let see once you get in where you
you're in like they they had a [ __ ]
show that was synonymous to any because
nobody else was doing anything
like that key and pill [ __ ] was cool but
it wasn't a day chappelle you understand
what i mean yeah yeah so
when earthquake got a radio show all
that kevin hart
started uh getting his uh
he got vodka doing jumanji doing all
these little movies with the rock
he funny but
he ain't funny yeah you funny and killed
in la because la is fake as [ __ ]
and then just a celebrity you know the
if you go to the other side of l.a the
south central where the real
[ __ ] hang out you go down to
brea and all that work you got latinos
living their life and ain't up there
being fake
and you killed that's different they
gonna love you but they gonna but they
got they're gonna hold you to a level
so
when i say these things you know he's
still funny kevin but kevin don't have
to work as hard you understand what i'm
saying
chris rockbite gonna come out funnier
than all of them
if if he wants to because at the moment
if he he
he writes this [ __ ] the way he supposed
to he could come out funny and all of
them because he he went to he got
he got something terribly done to him
and he had a pull from that yeah kevin i
mean chris rock
uh tambourine
special
was probably the best special ever
watching his
super vulnerable too like talking about
his porn addiction and things like that
talk about his divorce yeah and his
divorce like super vulnerable think
about thinking about how he said he said
a powerful thing he's sitting up in this
[ __ ]
with all these lawyers
and he they all these lawyers trying to
take my money he said damn i just made
it yeah you know that's a powerful
saying there you understand what i'm
saying so
you that that's what i look at because i
look at the greats george carlin richard
pryor richard pryor man what made him
great that's why i get on stage to talk
about my
vulnerabilities i don't i don't get on
stage i don't that's why people like to
come and see me too because
i don't pick on them
more than i pick on me
i pick on the idiotic see this dumb [ __ ]
like when that my special is about kobe
is it's a lot of things about it are
done you can sit up and throw a frowny
face and make it act like it's serious
but if you start take that goddamn layer
off and look
in that picture and realize that they
was [ __ ] with us
donald trump was trying to joke about it
and we wouldn't even get it
think about it people people die
they show their funeral
uk
i just said that [ __ ] on stage about
world war three
they
you if you don't watch movies you need
to watch every movie and start learning
from these movies because the wag the
dog
come on man
that [ __ ]
the war over i ain't heard no more about
have you
i heard dave chappelle got attacked the
headlines have just exactly yeah yeah
yeah you understand what i'm
saying you're crying
the news can't even keep nothing will
smith them helped us
because it slapped us into something
else where we stopped falling into this
dumb [ __ ] where we are real again
you understand what i'm saying i was out
it was it bothered me that he slapped
chris rock because i was like
[ __ ] that was wrong dawg i heard
that i heard for chris and i'm gonna
tell you something i i i think i've said
this before i am a major fan of real
quill smith i met will smith when he
opened up his uh uh studio called the
boom boom room he had a big ass
uh
play uh studio they were trying to put
music down and i was invited nick cannon
was with christy milan at that time i
highlighted chris i knew i knew nick way
back
will smith was in the middle of
everybody looking like like black jesus
everybody was all around that whale's
meal and i said hey he pointed to me and
i went hey hey and i reached out and he
shook my [ __ ] hand
and
i was a fan the rest of my life after
that [ __ ] yeah i mean i seen jada she
was going on in the back but i was just
sitting up there in an amazement that
just how cool this brother was and it's
persona it's just so wonderful you
understand and i understand how he got
chris to lower his guard and slap him
because he is
[Music]
he slapped me you know
and then that just took the way that you
didn't even have to do that dude you're
will smith
you could have said keep my wife's name
on your [ __ ] mouth from the chair
yeah and chris rockwood said i'm sorry
and moved on with the show i guarantee
i wouldn't not that i'm scared of them i
respect them too much
to just like i'm sorry bro because all
the [ __ ] they going through in that life
in their house i feel bad for him man
because i'm looking like dude
i understand any man that loves his
woman like i love my wife man and
sometimes you you let them have
too much of your
of your
your heart
and then when you pull back you look
like a bad guy
because you're trying to keep them happy
because you love him but then sometimes
a woman she loves you but you can't
if you read the bible god didn't want
men to get married he said but if you
can't and i said that on stage when you
talk about a good a good man a good
woman a good a wife is a good thing but
that's one of the excerpts of the bible
he didn't want you to get a wife because
he'd take your interest away from him
huh
read it whoa read that read the
description all right because see that
the main thing about that people don't
understand
we all read that part because that's the
woman part but we don't read the honest
part because yes the carnal lust yes
that but god really didn't want you to
do because he know
that that woman think about adam and eve
he
disrespected god listen to a damn snake
god just made her ass she get down there
listen to a snake started eating
in front of the tree analysis she wasn't
even a damn tree and now he told her
look hell for this is my job for you
yeah he tell me i don't know he's
talking about he's in the scripture for
sure
i'm paraphrasing that heifer there yeah
i think
something something like that you know
look at a woman
but but he told he told her
that you know he told her but then she
listened to a damn snake
but
adam's
job was
to check her kill that snake
and get it but he didn't he wasn't on
his job because god gave him something
spectacular you know that booty was good
that was in the scripture too i believe
yeah
that fresh from the source god god made
a oh he may he you know god don't push
[ __ ] off the bat that's where that's
where eating groceries came from yeah
right
groceries that damn right then girls
they're going that's the garden eating
like that
that's the fruit of knowledge that tree
is right there hey
you know you know eve was off the chain
and and she was beautiful god don't play
okay so
when he made her and then she disobeyed
and
he disobeyed
she
she got man
mad at him like look
he tried to save her he ran off with her
instead of coming to ask god for
forgiveness they could have went back in
the garden even if he would say i'm
sorry lord please forgive me he would
have god would have forgave him he
wouldn't adam was his first
is you know his first child that he was
trying to give you know he named the
handle without the thing when he just
knew earth he was doing but he he didn't
say sorry
he didn't he didn't apologize because he
was a father he would have been like all
right i understand
i know it was good boom boom boom he
could have had that candy talk with god
because yeah man this booty change
everybody
you see gotta get bullied they totally
did
you sure you got boys when they they
were goofy and y'all could play hang on
nick didn't know he get with cindy and
you can't even hear everywhere what the
[ __ ] you've been doing roger where the
hell are you hey man
i'm in a relationship now the burning
bush right get around a little bit
look
all through the bible women have been
very destructive in a man's thought
because he wouldn't never give it up
david killed
a man after guy's own heart killed uh
had her husband go off the water so he
can get with
bathsheba hmm
that's in the bible yeah i got to brush
up on my bible
i just look like a youth pastor i'm not
right yeah i know you got it
glad you joined us today for open book
testament because i'm here to
yeah but no i mean dude well see the
thing is i've been i'm 53 man you know
i'm getting closer to heaven than
anybody you know i'm getting close to
heaven every day so i want to understand
of course that life you know can i say
it i mean there's something this is
breaking news right here i didn't even
tell it to comedy hype i mean
i got 10 more years in this comedy game
yeah i got about 12 more years in the
comedy game i'm retiring i'm going to be
a minister what
why 12
well i'll be 65. oh you're catching
retirement like you're a teacher or
something
i'm going right i'm going to start and
if i say one soul
that's all i need you know i just i owe
god that
because he blessed me to make a living
doing something
telling jokes i'm not giving that no
product or nothing i'm telling jose and
making it great living there and i don't
want to reward him with a soul or
something that i could give back to
yeah like when i started comedy i was
about to graduate college and then i
prayed on was like do i need to follow
this degree in business or do i need to
follow like this comedy thing i've been
always wanting to do and i prayed on it
and then like woke up the next day like
oh i'm gonna go do comedy but i haven't
really yeah i feel like in the show
business you do doing business you're
doing show me yeah yeah that's true i
just i just haven't i guess giving back
in a way like like you're saying you
want to like give back i haven't really
always
see you pay your tithes in offering
that's giving back take that twenty
dollars and get the load out of that
200.
you know that that's all it is he don't
ask for much okay that don't bother you
about something god that story the
prodigal son you remember but he gave
all his riches to his first son he took
it and he left when party kicked it and
everything
wound up being broke after he spent all
his money eating with swine came back
and apologized his father and said
hey man i'll be a slave just let me come
back home be a slave his father said you
ain't gonna be no slave you're my son a
player
bring out my fattest calf my son is
returned to me and the thing about that
what they're telling you guys say
you don't matter what you've done i'll
forgive you and let you come back
it's nothing you can do unless you
commit suicide where you can't you know
you're dead you're here and i gotta you
gotta go i'm sorry you i could have
saved you but otherwise than that
he understands um
he understands that i mean dude we this
game is fickle but you know you get that
10 percent and thank you man you just
don't turn away from him okay so it's
simple man and like i said man i don't
i'm not gonna ever sell my show
for
for
video fame you know what i'm saying
because see you look at dave chris
you look at kev
those guys and i ain't saying they said
they so don't get me wrong
tiffany has they always in the eye
everybody looking at him
i'm in the eye
a lot it seemed like sometimes it turned
out louder sometimes it turns down but i
can't go a lot of places without being
recognized i'm getting recognized right
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh yeah oh
my god i gotta get off the plane in uh
newark new jersey just 50 students came
from atlanta from a business convention
it was just here and they saw me and one
kid walks over the you know the the
representative and he said excuse me
anybody said you look like you from
breaking bad i said yeah well i guess
because i am here you are kid freak all
white kids too
oh my god oh my god man they surrounded
then it became a q a taking pictures of
the photo op it was incredible it was
wonderful
you know and i mean and the thing about
it is i i can't believe i didn't even
have many lines i think if you count all
my episodes of breaking bad i got 10
lines
but you're unforgettable when people see
you like they don't forget yeah i guess
so so so but in that i realized how much
god has blessed me man and i mean dude
me from jelly joe's i'm on a drama
a big
probably the biggest
tv show that'll ever exist beside the
sopranos yeah for real people been
talking about bringing bad and it's been
over for a long time they did a little
movie and they weren't even about
breaking bad it was about jesse
uh so
so in in that aspect i look at man you
know you asked me like do i think i'm
sure i i know i am i can't
i can't get what i think
is success like you say 10 years i can't
get what i think it's a set but i know
i am successful and and think about it i
can't take it away from that instead of
stop lying to myself then man i'm
ultimately blessed i got everybody on
payroll my family i'm taking care of
everybody i'm you know
uh my son is healthy he lives a life
where he buys
tennis shoes off a
fight club for two grand and little kid
and he i mean he walking i can get what
i want when i want it you know so
my
to a limit but you know i i know that i
am
blessed and i know that i am successful
and so when you like you said i can't ha
i have a lot of expectations
you know and don't get wrong you always
want you have expectancy but you don't
put it on yourself because you're going
to get that you write out your prayer
book or write out your
uh put up your
vision board and just say where the heck
you want to go what you want to do
and you know and i think god gives it to
you when you're ready
boom you know because you may get all
that success and you're married
okay so you may lead your way no no no
no no no no don't listen babe don't
listen honey no no no i'm not saying no
i'm just saying before you ready oh
no before you got a kid no okay yeah i
ain't saying you're gonna leave your
wife's head before you're ready and see
because that's the thing about when you
ever seen crashing mm-hmm with pete
holmes yeah yeah i think
look at this this whole story is vice
versa she left him but think about it
you know his life started changing and
metamorphosizing
is this the thing about life
bills on his own you know you're going
to look up you watch you're going to
look up
and next thing you know you're you
you're going to be in every club around
the country
speaking i appreciate you saying that
you know you're going to be on self-made
and all that i watch
i mean you got the face you got you got
the face you can you could probably do
the ted bundy story i mean i had the
face this face isn't what it's about
anymore
this whole two white to fail phase
you still got it i mean i appreciate
that
like you look at gary owens right
i mean gary gary
he he reached his levels but gary nine
stop he keep going
he keeps going people his tenacity is
what make him anything that he do black
club gary goes hard for sure all the
time on that stage he don't play yeah
yeah yeah and i and i can't take that
away from him even though i talk about
his ass bad i i can't take that away
from him and i gotta respect him
preach yeah i see there are the features
on stage so we'll uh we'll get out of
here
as we uh as we end here is there any
closing advice for up and coming
comedians like any favorite comedy
advice that you've gathered over your
experience well i got something for you
it's all in my book on amazon called the
comedy school guide of stand up boom
there you go we'll link that in the show
notes yeah you can go get that right now
that's volume one volume two will be out
in a couple more months uh i'll be right
to take this i'll be giving these same
devices that i told you right here i
mean i mean
it's
basically it's a small book it's not a
thick book because a lot of it is just
it's a it's a it's a manual
you know emmanuel saying think you don't
have no 35 pages of what you're supposed
to do no it's like 70 something pages
and it got little lines in it to write
your jokes in perfect ideas so that
is how i believe
giving a comic
some advice because it's all on you
yeah and at the end
like this next book i'm gonna put a
little
reflector in there because i'm gonna say
it's you
you have to do it you know i mean
because i had a young guy had whole
foods today god bless a good kid he
working at work and making pizzas he
coming man he said he's i'm a big fan i
said thank you brady said man put me in
something man i can do it and that's so
funny to me and i said bro i said i
can't just can't come home you get you
in this booth right right i said dude
that's how life happened you think you'd
be selling pizza
you know but i did give him some of the
breakdown some things and i realized i'm
gonna have to write an actor's guide too
i love it of of little things that i
know i love it you know i'm just gonna
give you these the the you know just
some guidelines i'm not i can't give you
what i say in the book i don't know if
it's going to work for you
it's gotta do the work but my book on
amazon
right now
go get it baby
the final thing could you could you look
in the camera say your name and why
people should listen to hot breaths
was it hot breath hot breath okay right
here hot breath okay
uh hey this is lavell crawford comedian
grammy nominee
sag award winner
i'm talking about my
accolade
uh
and the reason why you should listen to
the hot breath is because this young man
here about to be a big star he ain't
gonna be doing it no more
we out you look honey it's working
thank you so much lavell man it's an
honor to sit down with you thank you so
much thank you for taking us out glad we
got this done already whoa
yeah awesome